hi herzlich willkommen zum heutigen
video leute ich habe nicht viel zeit und
aus diesem grund habe ich mir eine
stehende challandes genommen werde
einfach zusammen mit kommt wieder dieser
gegenstand neben der karte wasserhahn
zusammen mit luca mache ich diesen
stellen
wir probieren heute sachen anhand von
unseren füßen zu ertasten ja ich würde
sagen es ist ja immer eine aufs sofa
kriegt was auf diesen teppich gelegt und
das ding ist er fertig macht sich
irgendwie leichter das gedacht aber noch
eher später das ding ist dieser teppich
macht sich unbedingt leichter sachen
drüben eigentlich schwerer weil halt
richtig haare hat er wird verbindet uns
die augen und ich würde sagen lukrativ
erwiesen fange ich an mir schließlich
verschluckte anfängt gehen also ich muss
mit seinen verbindungen auf die augen
verbunden sind
du hast jetzt die sache hier liegen ja
toll dazu klopft es auch okay ich habe
eine idee als abbas ich dachte erst wenn
diese skateboards das gerät vor das
skateboarding die um die achsen
festzuschrauben einfach von längliches
teil fertig und die pasten gestürzt
nicht schlecht da wir nur wegen ihm
haften also ich habe erst gedacht
irgendwann der switch controller sodann
die augen
ja ok macht als sache neben wir jetzt
einfach mal
ich legte man hier hin und es liegt
jetzt zehn zentimeter fordert faktor
alter immer wieder die augen muss erst
mal irgendetwas finden das ist nun
erstmal testen und sehen kann erklärten
junge 1500 t shirt verriet ihr alles
nass wie überall ganz witzig findet mit
dabei
künftig will ich weiß nicht was sie was
passiert wenn ich falsch liege
ok es nötig hat sich angefühlt wie ein
politiker also mag sieht es jetzt mal
operieren kann
und hier kann ich bin also wir jetzt mal
als sache die wir ihnen hier hinlegen
einfach mal hier vorne hin direkt vor
ihnen
es geht direkt vor den füßen
[Gelächter]
unterschiedliche sachen einläutet die
schere packung ja dass du dich umbringen
ich habe mir den fuß gefixt
unter den haaren ok wird ich nehme jetzt
ein offenes feuer was sich da hinlegen
schon verraten
ich mache keine flecken gefunden für den
alltag aber inzwischen eine gefragte den
kurs vorerst beendet da dies noch weiter
los gehts nicht ganz richtig alten hasen
verkehr zwischen den orten eine fünfte
geschlossen
walter rotter fakt philips einer
schublade dass ich habe eine idee aber
ich will es nicht sagen also hier
falls diese technik des st
ich habe überhaupt keinen plan heißt
hedge-fonds oder nein als wenn ich
wieder warum liegen steuerlich
zuständigen arzt hat weil da fertig
anführt 10 cm fordern füße du hast du
natürlich zu reduzieren könnte nach
vorne gehen wird wir hatten eine falle
hingegen würde
ist es nicht nur um 54 ice strecken
nicht darin video auf
wir haben wieder aufgenommen für luca
mit den in wien bot sind deshalb dass
sie das werden die dingen dank geschaut
ob wir im bus rad zu drehen ist
logistisch wäre ich heute ganz kurz
berührt und das ding hat leider einfach
in meinem fuß gesteckt er nach 2 und
angefangen so dass wir jetzt die
allerletzte runde und liegt
so locker objekt liegt jetzt da und du
kannst du ich bin so froh dass hier
einfach gesetzt
[Musik]
ich glaube ich würde sagen nehme einfach
gegenstand befindet sich 50 meter vor
den fuss nicht gefährlich ja in gewisser
form ist schon gefährlich und zerstört
die menschen
das ist ja genau sagen wie viel da
fragst du etwa 20 01 10 15 niederlage
danke zum sieg zu sieg so läuft das
wasser heutigen video schaut euch
gefallen
[Musik]